METE ATAMEL: Hello, everyone.
My name is Mete Atamel.
I'm a Developer Advocate.
And today, I want to talk about
an app modernization story
with Cloud Run.
Back in early 2016, a
friend of mine and I--
we wanted to build a
news aggregator app.
In this app, we would go
and fetch news articles
from various news
sources, and we
would display them in a mobile
app in a clean timeline.
My friend worked on
the mobile front end
while I worked on the back end.
In this presentation, I want
to talk about the modernisation
journey or the back end.
The back end was initially
written with ASP.NET 4.6.
It was a Windows app, and it
was deployed on an IIS host.
There were three main services.
The reader would fetch
the right size feeds.
The transformer would convert
them into a common format
that we defined.
And the web API would serve the
feeds to the mobile front end.
The initial prototype, we worked
on, on a couple of weekends,
and it worked.
It was very easy to understand,
and it was very easier
to deploy because everything
was bundled together.
Also, the IIS host
was quite inexpensive.
At the same time, the app had
issues from the beginning.
First of all, there was too
much coupling between services.
All three services there
were all bundled together.
The developer experience of
the IIS host was not great.
Sometimes the machine where
our application was running on
would go down, and
we wouldn't know why.
Or if we had to look at the
logs of the application,
I had to FTP into the machine
and download the logs.
We didn't have any
kind of redundancy,
any kind of persistence,
or any kind of resilience.
So if there were any issues
with any of the services,
it could potentially bring
down our whole application.
But this was the
initial prototype,
and it was a good start.
And it served us well
for about a year.
But in 2017, we started looking
into moving our application
to a better place.
That's when we came
across Compute Engine.
Compute Engine-- they
are virtual machines
on Google Cloud
where you can have
as Linux or Windows-based
virtual machines.
So we took our app and we
deployed to a Windows Server
on Compute Engine.
Then we configured
it the way we liked.
And then, we created what's
called an instance template out
of our VM.
Instance template is kind of
like a snapshot of your VM.
And then you can use it to
create instance groups, which
are identical VMs load balanced
behind the Cloud Load Balancer.
With this setup,
we got redundancy.
We had two VMs running
our application,
we got load balancing
with Cloud Load Balancer,
and we also got
possibility of autoscaling
because with
instance groups, you
can set metrics and use
those metrics to autoscale
if you need to.
It was a very easy move.
We didn't have to
change our code.
We just had to deploy it to
do Windows Server on Compute
Engine.
And the developer
experience with Google Cloud
was much better.
We had integrated
logging with Stackdriver,
we had VM snapshots for
backup and recovery,
and we had easy access to
our VMs with remote RDP.
At the same time, things
were getting more expensive.
Instead of running on
a single machine shared
by other applications, we were
running on two dedicated VMs,
and we had Cloud Load
Balancer as well.
Even though it wasn't
that expensive,
it was more than we wanted
for a hobby application.
But this setup served us
well for a couple of years.
From 2017 to 2019, there
were a few interesting things
happening in the tech world,
especially in .NET world.
First of all, there was this new
version of the net called .NET
Core.
And the most interesting thing
about .NET Core is that it can
run on multiple platforms--
Linux, Mac, or Windows.
Secondly, there was a lot
of hype around containers.
Everyone was talking about
how to take a single monolith
application running
on a VM and how
to break it down
into smaller pieces
and run them in containers
in a much more efficient way.
Third, we had our
windows dependency.
Our application was a
Windows application.
And that limited our
deployment options,
and we wanted to get rid
of that at some point.
And last, it cost
our application.
Even though it wasn't that
much, it was still something
that we wanted to bring down.
So all of these forces came
into play, and in early 2019,
we started looking into how to
containerize our application.
Now, before containerization,
we had to first convert
our application from
.NET to .NET Core.
So we rewrote our
application as .NET Core 2.2,
the latest version at the time.
And this took a weekend.
We were pleasantly
surprised because we
were expecting at least couple
of weeks to do the conversion.
But we had all the
libraries that we needed,
and everything that
we were using on .NET,
they were already
available on .NET Core.
Now, once we rewrote our
application on .NET Core,
we freed ourselves from Windows,
and we could run on Linux.
That's when we got
into containerization.
We containerized our
application with Docker
using some base images
provided by Microsoft.
And then, we could
deploy to multiple places
in Google Cloud.
There were two good options--
first, Google Kubernetes
Engine, and second, App Engine.
We chose App Engine because all
we needed was a web front end.
And everything was
bundled together.
So App Engine served us well.
Google Kubernetes
Engine could have
been better because it
provided infrastructure
for more complex architectures.
But App Engine
was enough for us.
So that's why we
went App Engine.
With this setup, the Windows
license fees were out.
So our application
was running on Linux,
and it was cheaper to run.
We got hassle-free autoscaling.
Because in App Engine, you
get autoscaling without having
to do anything special.
And we got the nice
features of App Engine,
such as revision management
and traffic splitting.
But we were still running
on virtual machines.
App Engine does a good job of
hiding the fact that you are
running on virtual machines.
But behind the scenes,
on App Engine Flex,
you are running on
virtual machines,
and you need to pay those
virtual machines per second.
This meant that our
application, when it was not
used-- especially
during the evenings-- we
were still paying for
those VMs at all times.
Also, the deployments
of App Engine--
there were kind of slow.
It could take anywhere
from 5 to 10 minutes.
Even though it
wasn't a big problem,
it slowed us down during
our development cycle.
Around mid-2019, something new
came along called Cloud Run.
And the whole
premise of Cloud Run
is to bring serverless
features to containers.
This was very exciting for
us, because our application
was already containerized.
And we were already
looking into running it
in a serverless way, especially
when it comes to billing.
So in mid-2000-- also, I
should mention that Cloud Run,
it has a couple of use cases.
First one is public endpoints.
Cloud Run is very good for that.
And also, the second use
case is private endpoints
where you need to do some
kind of background task.
Cloud Run is a good
fit for that as well.
And both of these use cases were
the use cases or application.
We had the web front
end that was public.
And we had internal
services that
could be private
endpoints on Cloud Run.
And also, the best part of
Cloud Run was its billing time.
In Cloud Run, even
though your container
might be running for a while,
you only pay for the time
that the requests
are being handled.
This meant that our
application, when
it wasn't being used
in the evenings,
it was scaled down to
zero and we paid nothing.
So with this in mind, we tried
to deploy our application
to Cloud Run in mid-2019.
To do that, first, we
upgraded our application
to the latest version
of ASP.NET Core 3.0.
And then, deploying to Cloud
Run was a single command--
gcloud app run deployed,
and it was there.
You didn't have to
change anything.
Now with this, we got
serverless billing.
And this really brought down
our billing considerably.
Because we weren't paying for
anything when our application
wasn't being used.
We also got awesome developer
experience with Cloud Run.
We had fast deploys, so we
could deploy within seconds
instead of minutes.
And we got integrated
logging with Stackdriver.
And we got all the awesome
features of Cloud Run
with traffic management, and
revision management, and so on.
At the same time, we
were still running
as a single monolithic
application.
And we had monolith issues.
Those monolith issues
were, first, scaling.
We could only scale
all or nothing.
If we had to scale the web
front end because there
were more users, we had to scale
the reader and the converter
as well.
And this wasn't ideal
for us because we
had to scale individual
services as we needed.
But we couldn't do that
in a monolith application.
Second, we had an
issue with cold starts.
So when our application
wasn't being used,
it was scaled down to zero.
And this was great for billing.
But at the same time, when
the first user came along,
our application would wake up.
It didn't have any
kind of persistence.
So it had to go and
fetch the feeds,
then it had to
transform them, and it
had to serve to the user.
So this meant that
the first user could
wait for a while for
the data to show up,
and this was
becoming a big issue.
Third, all of the
state was in memory.
We didn't have any
kind of backup state.
And we wanted to have
something more persistent.
And lastly, we didn't have a way
to update individual services.
Most of the times,
we didn't have
to update our reader
or our web API,
but we had to change
rules about how
to transform their RSS feeds.
Even though we
only had to change
the small piece or
our location, we
had to update our
whole application
because it was a monolith.
So with these issues
in mind, in stage four,
we started looking into
how to break down monolith
into smaller microservices.
This was early 2020.
And this is what
we came up with.
First, we had this new
service called Reader.
This is a private
Cloud Run service.
It's private, meaning it
doesn't have a public endpoint.
And all it does is,
it goes and fetches
RSS feeds and brings them back.
Now, this Reader is being
called by Cloud Scheduler, which
is a scheduling service
on Google Cloud.
And Scheduler would call Reader
once an hour, every hour,
and Reader would go
and fetch the feeds.
And it would save the
feeds into Cloud Storage,
which is a cloud-based
object storage service.
Now, once the fees are
saved into Cloud Storage,
Cloud Storage can
generate notifications
to a Pub/Sub topic.
And these
notifications, they can
be served to another Cloud
Run service called Converter.
This Converter, it's another
private Cloud Run service.
And it will look at the list
of rules that we defined,
and it will transform these RSS
feeds from different formats
into a common format
that we defined.
Once they're put into
the common format,
they're saved into
Cloud Firestore.
This is a fully
managed, NoSQL database.
And it's perfect
for JSON-like data.
And then, we had another public
Cloud Run service called Web.
This was the public front
end of our application.
The users-- the end
users, the mobile app,
would go and ask for the
feeds from the web service.
And the web would
just look at Firestore
and fetch the latest
data from there.
As you can see, we
brought our monolith
into three separate
microservices.
Two of them are private
services because they
don't need to be public.
One of them is public.
They are totally
independent from each other.
So the reader doesn't have
to know about the Converter,
and the Web doesn't need
to care about the Converter
or the Reader.
They are all
event-driven, so they
don't need to call each
other in a synchronous way.
And they can be
individually scaled.
So if we have more users, we
can only up-scale web front end.
We don't have to scale the
Reader or the Converter.
And they can be individually
updated as well.
Usually, they'll need to
update Reader and Web.
Because the way we read
and the way we serve
is always the same.
But we have to update
Converter quite often.
Because the rules around RSS
feeds, they change quite a lot.
And this setup
allows us to do that.
So with this setup, even
though it's a little bit more
complicated, we
so all the issues
that we had with the
previous application.
Now, the lessons learned in
this transformation journey--
first of all,
transformation does not
have to be all or nothing.
As you can see from
our journey, it
was a step-by-step
transformation
where each step added something
new to our application,
removed some legacy, and opened
the way for new technologies.
Secondly, sometimes
you need to use
non-optimal optimal
solutions to get ready
for optimal solutions.
For example, in our case,
when you look at it,
App Engine Flex was probably
not the most optimal solution
because we were
still running on VMs.
Cloud Run was the
optimal solution
because we needed an
event-driven microservices
kind of environment.
And that's what Cloud
Run allowed us to do.
But to get from our
VM to Cloud Run,
we had to use App
Engine in the middle.
And by doing that, we went from
a .NET Windows app to a .NET
Core app running on App Engine.
It wasn't ideal, but
it served us well
because in the
next iteration, we
could much easier move from
App Engine Flex to Cloud Run.
Third, even simple things like
lift and shift to the cloud
can have huge benefits.
In our application, by moving
from IAS to Google Cloud,
we didn't have to really
change any of our code.
All we had to change was
our deployment and then
where we deployed.
But by doing that, we had
instance tablets, instance
groups, and load balancing.
And with those, we got more
resilience and redundancy.
So, to get benefits,
you don't always
need to change your code.
You can just change
your environment
and still get those benefits.
And at some point, you should
expect some kind of rewrite.
Especially if you want
to use the benefits
of the new environment
that you're running in.
For example, in our case,
when we deployed to Cloud Run,
initially, we deployed
as a single monolith.
We got some benefits,
but it wasn't
all the benefits of Cloud Run.
To truly use the
benefits of Cloud Run,
we had to actually decompose our
application into microservices.
And we had to make
them event driven.
And for that, we had
to restructure our code
and had to break it down.
So it was a lot of
work that was needed
in order to use Cloud Run in
a way that made sense for us.
And we all talk about
monolith applications,
and how they're bad, and how
we should break them down
into smaller pieces.
And it's usually true.
But at the same time,
this is a hard process.
It involves refactoring and
restructuring your code.
And then it involves
figuring out
how these new services will
communicate with each other,
whether it's going
to be event driven,
or whether it's going
to be synchronous,
and what kind of storage
they're going to use.
So there's all these questions
that you need to answer.
Monolith decomposition--
it's something
that you should take
it very seriously.
And you should have
a really good reason
to do it if you want to do it.
So that's all I have for today.
Hopefully, this was useful.
And if you want to read
more about this application,
I wrote a blog
post series where I
explain in more detail what
this application is about
and give you more
details about it.
And the code is,
as well, on GitHub.
So if you want to take a
look at the back end code,
it's out there.
And thanks very
much for listening.
Thank you.